[Music]
where does that come from
i think canada cool skater talk it's not
cool skater
let me tell you something right now okay
i think he's right bucky i know
jimmy jim greco i know andrew reynolds
i know a lot of skaters okay they've
never said [ __ ] a
[ __ ] a they have no they haven't i
want proof yeah i've i've done i've done
a sketch with tony hawk
i've done i've met um all kinds of
skaters in my life
street you know but george
style freestyle he like still says
things like we'll bite my shorts
you know so what do i say what was that
like bite my shorts
like i should bring that back i haven't
used that but uh you if you say
by my shoulders things like dollars to
donuts
oh yeah i don't even know what have you
heard of that before let's go through
all of those
but [ __ ] a though where does that is
you think it comes from the skate
yes culture it does no way oh hell yeah
it's just
like give me one skater name me one
skater aside from the skaters i just
mentioned
uh matt hamill who i hung out with in
high school isn't that the deaf guy from
the ufc
[Laughter]
is he a deaf guy from the um he's the
deaf guy in the u.s no no who's he
signed by what what's going on he's just
the buddy that i skated with in high
school
is he pro though no no i need a
professional
uh skater that you know
um well then here's my point
is you don't know what they say
[Laughter]
all right i know i know what they say
the streets level you know yeah
you know what they say you know what
they say at the big time level you know
i know what
i know you know what's happening in the
streets you know you know uh kalisto and
me when i lived in silver lake we are
name dropping so
hardcore right now please there's a guy
that lives in silver like he's not a
skater but we owned a skate shop
called juvie do you know that a good
name
i just remember i didn't know the name
of it yeah you've talked about a long
time back
yeah anyway a lot of skateboarders
because we had a vert ramp
so what cool slang did they use there
they didn't say [ __ ] a
what did they say name one thing uh just
landed a triple flip kick
awesome like with the standard they
don't even i wouldn't believe that they
don't even have to
drop an f-bomb dude that's awesome come
on dude that's [ __ ] awesome let me
get this straight yeah
you successfully opened a business on
your own
yeah it could go bankrupt in a year
[Laughter]
we opened it like did you have a
business plan did you get like
a business loan like you did all of that
no what it was was i you know when i
when i was in san diego i
um when i was 19 i was at a
there used to be a coffee shop in um
pacific beach called
zanzibar i don't know if it's still
there but zanzibar used to be open 24 7.
there was a zanzibar in santa monica
there's a coffee shop
um they had um no it was like a dance
hall kind of
maybe there's a bunch of zanza bars yeah
and there's
there's probably zanzibar smoothies
zanzibar movie theater
somewhere in the world but in this
specific situation
yeah it was a [ __ ] coffee shop
sweetie okay sorry okay
supports me you just [ __ ] pushed me
over the edge all right
all right so anyway so at two in the
morning i used to go there and play
chess
ah what why does that bother you why
does that bother you
because i know that's not who he truly
was bobby
and you've admitted what is that no you
[ __ ] yeah you've admitted this to me
you won't admit it to other people but
you've admitted this to me that
you wanted to fit a look
you wanted to read the story of
dostoyevsky and
have people watch you play chess like it
was it was not that you enjoyed it
yeah you just wanted to be i had no
shoes i would
see the way i'm crossing my legs now you
would sit like that i would purposely
slip by and sit like this
i'd have a cigarette in one hand
expresso on the other hand
film yeah and i would play
sad piano music played in the background
of everything he did then
he was he lived in black and white we
talked about existentialism he's like
yeah
have you seen have you seen regard
have you seen the movie yeah [ __ ]
[ __ ] you but anyway yeah although jim is
a great movie
great film anyway um back to my story
back in the day um i met this other guy
named kalisto
hernandez he was hispanic and
you know we just became friends and um
he isn't he was an actor at the time and
he moved to la
and i moved up right after he did and we
lived together
in silverlake and then one day he's like
i want to open up skate store
and i go what do you need for me this is
right one
i was making money and i gave him money
when i was
the early days of my mad tv years and we
opened up the skate store
and it went bankrupt but it it became
bad between him and i
after because of that because because of
that business
because um well one thing that he did
was
so basically i was the money guy but he
was on the he owned
the thing even though my brother steve
helped out making the plays like he he
he used to [ __ ] drill and
and a cement sander and all kinds of
handy yeah my brother
yeah my brother would wear this mask and
just go to work
and my mother doesn't know you know he
just figured it out i guess yeah because
he needs help like setting up his ikea
bed
you know i mean like he calls me for
stuff like that and bobby said he was
doing cement
i know i was like well you're laying
down floors but you can't do that
yeah i don't know anyway and then one
day i went into the store
i just have a shirt i liked so i grabbed
it and i go i'm going to take this shirt
it's a medium he goes all right well
that's 49.95
and i by the way i had thousands and
thousands he had no money
invested in it kalisto didn't yeah and i
go
no i mean i'm i give you the thousands
of dollars
he's like yeah but that was just a loan
like i own the
you know business so it's 49.95
he didn't even give you wholesale on
that yeah yeah and i go
[ __ ] it i'm not i'm not [ __ ] you what
yeah i'm not
paying for a shirt when i gave you money
you
oh my god this guy is bad i know you'd
like him if you met him though i'm sure
i would yeah yeah
but the reason why i don't hang out with
them is because when they think
he he asked for another 10 000
to save the business so i gave him the
money and then it went bankrupt
and then he looked at me goes well i'm
gonna
i owe you 10 grand even though i had so
much more money and
invested in it and so i go all right
well
[ __ ] it and then his dad died but he
didn't know his dad
um his dad died in mexico but his dad
was rich
oh so he came for money then no he
didn't
he was adopted in america oh